there's new information about a
whistleblower claim that started a
confrontation between the Director of
National Intelligence and the House
Intelligence Committee Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill Nancy what do we know
about that whistleblower report well the
report Michelle appears to Center in
part around communications between
President Trump and the president of
Ukraine and mr. Trump's lawyer seemed to
concede last night that he wanted
Ukraine to look into one of mr. Trump's
top political rivals in exchange for
military aid if the President of the
United States said to the president of
Ukraine investigate the corruption in
your country that has a bearing on our
2016 election isn't that what he's
supposed to do
the president's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
said mr. Trump didn't do anything wrong
in a phone call with the president of
Ukraine but Giuliani admitted that he
did ask the Ukrainian government to
investigate former Vice President Joe
Biden and his son hunter who worked for
a Ukrainian gas company you did ask
Ukraine to look into Joe Biden of course
I did Giuliani claims Biden himself
tried to bribe the Ukrainian government
to get his son out of legal trouble but
that claim is unsubstantiated and even
before this whistleblowers complaint
came to light Democrats had launched an
investigation to determine whether the
president and his allies set up a quid
pro quo demanding that Ukraine
investigate a 2020 presidential rival in
exchange for military aid at the present
United States whoever he is has every
right to tell the president of another
country you better straighten out the
corruption in your country if you want
me to give you a lot of money the
contents of that whistleblower complaint
might shed some light on all this but
right now the Acting Director of
National Intelligence is refusing to
hand it over to Congress do you believe
that the White House or the President
himself are pressuring the Acting
Director of National Intelligence not to
hand this information over to you all I
do know is this I don't know
whether the white houses is directly
involved because we can't get an answer
that question but we do know that they
are making some claim that a privilege
may apply well that narrows the category
who may be intervening here a former
senior US official told CBS News that
the president has a lot of leeway in
these conversations with foreign leaders
and the things that he says to them what
we know right now is that the President
himself is defending his actions and
tweeting that he knows that a lot of
people listen in to those conversations
and so he would never say anything
inappropriate
Anthony Nancy Cordes Thank You Nancy